we um
made a video to mark the passing of
clive sinclair but you work with
sinclair can you take us through some of
those i want to say fantastic days but
perhaps it was just a job tell me about
it
it was a slightly random thing actually
the way it happened uh i
my phd was in algebra
but i'd always had an interest in
computers because my father worked at
the national physical laboratory with
computers there and showed them to me
from an early age
and got me programming in basic things
like that so after i finished my maths
phd i thought well i'm still interested
in computers so i'd see the big wide
world by applying to all the computer
companies i could find in cambridge
and see if any of them had a job
so i wasn't working directly for the
sinclairs but through this company
called nine tiles
owned and managed by
a guy called john grant and he had
already done the the rom for the zx80
and
for the zx81 which was the successor to
that
they wanted a massive floating point
maths pack and so they thought well they
get a mathematician to do that and they
took me on
and i ended up not only doing the
floating point math but also all the
other things that the zx81
had in addition to the zx80
um
when it uh when it was all completed
i wrote the manual which they used and
um to say what i'd put into it
and
i had a
i mean frankly rather idiosyncratic
touch to writing manuals but it
seemed to to ring a bell with people
and um so once the zx81 was out of the
way we started work on the successor
which is the zx8
spectrum so the way it worked was my
actual office was in was with nine tiles
that started off in ely and then moved
to a village called water beach just
outside cambridge
but i'd go into cambridge quite a lot um
to work with the sinclair team which was
then in a
about
two or three floors in a very narrow
building in king's parade just opposite
kings college
and so that's where the actual sinclair
people were working there was um
uh their main technical person was a guy
called jim westwood
and uh so he does
i think he did the the uh the hardware
for the um
for the zx81 and then my job was to
write some
code in z80 assembly language load into
roms plug it into the hardware as it's
being developed and see how it works
and there was also a designer there
called rick he designed the cases
and um so for the spectrum they got in
um
a guy called richard outbacker so he was
doing hardware and it worked the same
way i'd write software blow it into the
rom
um see how it works
direct it and you know gradually develop
it so the hardware and software were
being developed in parallel it's
interesting you mentioned the manual as
well because i think a generation of
computer coders would like to say thank
you to you um
because i have to confess to not having
had a sinclair machine but i know
friends of mine and that's how they
started coding because they looked in
that manual and you explained very
clearly how to to go about starting from
scratch and writing some code it was a
very very good menu actually and in the
manual was all these little example
programs that went through basic basic
was the language that it used it was a
basic machine using the basic language
but somewhere along the line it became
clear that
people were also wanting to use it to
write machine code so
that wasn't something i'd had any
experience of myself but i thought well
i'd better put in the information that
would enable them to do that effectively
so they'd need
various addresses
and
so that they can interact with the with
the operating system
and uh that seemed to have worked as
well they were able to write machine
code that interacted effectively with
the rest of the machine so i was quite
pleased with the way that turned out
what was the biggest challenge you had
done you've got a mathematician's
background and an interest in computing
but how do you where'd you start with
that i hadn't done any programming in my
um
you know in my degree courses but i had
done some programming before i went to
university
uh under my father's interest in fact he
got me a job for nine months between
school and
university at the national physical
laboratory doing some programming so i
had some programming experience
so i just uh you know it just seemed to
me
a fairly natural thing to do so
it took a little while to to work out
the idiosyncrasies of the z80
cpu
and
i think
the biggest challenge that covered the
whole thing was basically the
limitations of memory so the rom was
only a fixed size it was something like
uh
i don't know i think it's about 4k
for the zx81 and 8 maybe 16k for the
spectrum which just sounds
you know today you'd measure it all in
in mexico
but it all had to be fitted into the
wrong so that you had to use all the
tricks in the book for
reducing the number of bites that you
used so
we kind of weren't allowed to write to
call a subroutine and then return
straight afterwards because
that sort of wasted
um
a push to the stack and and then a pump
so you had to just jump to the sub
routine and the return would take care
of itself once you're there some of the
numerical bits in the maths pack were
a bit of a challenge i remember going to
a lot of
work to
find out what was the most effective way
of calculating logarithms i think i was
using chebychev polynomials
um
something like that
so there was one particular calculation
where it took several days to work out
what were going to be the most efficient
ways of reducing the problem
but uh that is interesting
i think some of the things i was most
pleased with were bits where
you know
like the beat the sounds right so you
say beep and you say uh
how long for and what pitch
and um
and then it does it so that was uh
there's a kind of standard way of doing
it where you give the pitch in terms of
the frequency because basically it's
just producing
certain number of clicks per second
that's not at all the way you'd want to
write down music so
i wanted to make it more usable so
i had to
work out how to express the pitch in
terms of semitones
and that was
so to convert from the pitch to the
frequency you actually have to use some
some logarithms
and so i had the logarithms in the maths
pack and that was uh that would seem
fine except that they were very accurate
but quite slow so i had to write some
much quicker ones that were good enough
for the purposes just to make it work
and so i was pleased with the way it
came out because
lots of other computers i'd seen
you know you you could control the uh
um
control of the the pitch and the
frequency but it was all a bit difficult
uh whereas with the the spectrum you
could um it was very easy to raise it up
a semitone you just
add one to all the parameters and
i thought that was
i thought that's the way to do it what
the way it's been done previously what
else was a challenge deadlines the
deadline was always the next exhibition
so you have to get it you have to get
something demonstrable by the next
exhibition and that's just the way that
the sinclair product cycle works
so um sometimes the uh what you saw at
the exhibition wasn't quite what was
intended to go to the public but
something that just
you needed to show something and yeah
that's right yeah did you work with uh
sir clive at all
not really he's not a technical guy he
had a very good intuition for
uh costs
so he
one
the critical thing is
every piece of hardware that goes into
it has to be paid there's a cost of it
per unit
wherever whereas every bit of software
that goes into it
there's
one single overall cost when somebody me
or john grant or whoever writes it and
after that it's just divided by however
many
machines you make so he knew that very
well he knew exactly that every
transistor in the machine
would cost more um
so he got other people to work out how
to
how to implement that to to get the cost
down
but um
that was the main concern of his so that
there's there's very little interaction
between
me and him while uh
while i was i was doing my work in fact
i remember at one point sitting down in
front of a spectrum and say here it is
have a go and he's oh i don't know how
to use those
things i think that's true you had no
idea how you actually programmed a basic
machine did you ever have any kind of
input into how much of that uh memory
you know the k that you had to work with
or did they just say
here's 4k
that's a given
in the manual
i wanted to put in a very simple example
that
that users could just type in themselves
so i thought frerajaka
[Music]
and then i thought i mean this is
getting a bit fancy and i thought well
why not spice it up and instead you use
malay used the same thing but in a minor
key in his first symphony
so i thought oh i'll do that instead and
i had some fanciful remarks about what
the mahler music was doing so
that was basically verajaka in the minor
key that you could type in and program
and get it to do it and then as a little
exercise at the end of the
chapter i jokingly said
uh program up the whole of mahler's
first symphony which was um could only
be a joke because the spectrum only had
its one speaker
whereas the symphony obviously has a
whole orchestra full of different
instruments playing different notes
so
nobody could ever do that and then um
30 years later
some guys got together
and thought well actually we can do that
if we get enough spectrums all working
together
so they got all their spectrums and they
got a raspberry pi to synchronize them
so that was the kind of conductor
and they they put together a video
[Music]
wasn't the whole symphony but it was the
whole of that movement
so i thought
what a waste
so if i'd known
30 years ago
that
i could make a fanciful suggestion and
30 years later people and computers
would get together and and make a
reality of it
i'd have thought of something more
useful more world changing but never
mind
after the spectrum richard outfasso
he and i
were thinking well why are we making all
this money for clive sinclair why can't
we just make it for ourselves it's easy
to forget now that it was this was
delivering a computer
for
a hundred pounds